one of the really painful effects of the
pandemic is the impact it's had on the
vibrant sports community
right here in southern nevada so many
kids las vegas athletes really
struggling now to find some active
outlets
but still pursue dreams of continuing
sports in college
john treats joining us tonight in studio
with more on that tonight john
competitors want nothing more than a
shot thousands of talented los vegans
have been kept on the sidelines as their
peers around the country
play on this is the struggle of three
young men fighting for a football future
it was supposed to look like this the
satisfaction of achievement
only surpassed by the sensation of
ambience
instead it looked like this a football
loving desert
deserted and any chance to shine
shut down football season was the best
times of my life you know
school was fun shoot everything was fun
you know you
build bonds that last forever 35 states
played football with strict covet
guidelines in the fall
nevada was not one of them several other
states added a truncated spring session
nevada punted centennial senior
quarterback colton tinney led the
bulldogs to their first state
championship
game he threw for 27 touchdowns last
year
and colleges craved more do it again
they said
5 11 on a good day i don't run a 4-4
can't throw the ball 80 yards but i'm a
good football player
and so it's frustrating to try to get
recruited through the process where they
just look at these
at the tangibles how tall you are how
fast you are and when i have good film
so it's frustrating to not get that
extra year film
colton's college plans are still stuck
same for sharon thomas the paolo verde
running back had 1200 yards rushing and
the respect of all of his peers
when i first got my jersey and i first
played my game scored my first touchdown
it was always a dream of mine to be able
to play
college football absent a scholarship
offer sharon is going to gamble with
junior college
so is work out partner and one-time
rival jayshawn scroggins
the las vegas high highlight reel had
division one interest as a junior
but those schools went with prospects in
states that played they start calling
you every week to
barely calling you at all the class of
2021 will have success without ceremony
but strength is defined by those who
keep
going i know quarterbacks that came out
of juco like aaron rodgers you know cam
newton
josh josh allen you know they're playing
in big time super bowl games playoff
games
if they're working during the pause just
wait till they press
play it's affected the process but it
hasn't affected the goal i'm still
still set on playing and i still believe
that i can play at a high level it's
very upsetting but
just always got to stay positive and
just keep moving forward and what a
story that will be
feeling left out in football is merely a
snapshot of a troubling picture of
young people looking to connect
encourage those struggling with mental
health to talk about it
better days are ahead